[موسيقى]
وفق ضيفنا اليوم هو موعد انطلاق مونديال
قطر 2022 ربطه بوصول اولي فريق المشارك في
البطوله الى قطر ويصل بالفعل بعد ساعات
الفريق الياباني الوعد تقول قطر لملايين
عشاق الكره المستديره وتعيدهم بتجربه لا
تنسى وتاكد انها جاهزه ومستعده هل العالم
مستعد لعلها الفرصه الاكبر منذ احداث
الحادي عشر من سبتمبر 2001 كي يرى الغرب
المنطقه من منظور مختلف بعيدا عن الصوره
النمطيه السلبيه التي لحقت بالانسان
العربي والمسلم والتي كرسها الاعلام
الغربي
هكذا وصفه امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن
حمد ال ثاني من طول اليوم الاول واعتبرته
جماهير المنطقه العربيه البالغه 450 مليون
نسمه ملك لها دافعت عنهم ضد الحملات غير
المسبقه التي طالته منذ اليوم الاول
وتتفاعل حدها كل ما اقترب الموعد وعلى
المستوى الرسمي ايضا وفي ختام قمه العربيه
منذ ايام اكد اعلان الجزائر على دعمه قطر
في استضافه الماضيه ورفض حمله التشويه
والتشكيك المقرضه التي تبالها اما الاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم الفيفا والذي اعلن ان
من اهم اهدافه اخذ رياضه كره القدم الى
اماكن جديده واراضي جديده فقد اكد رئيسه
ان البطوله ستكون الافضل في التاريخ منذ
انطلاقها لكن منذ بدا اسيره شبهات حول ملف
قطر وتساؤلات عن فوزي رغم تاكيد التحقيقات
النزاهته لم تتوقف الحجمه وترحم مؤدجوها
رائعه عن حقوق الانسان وحقوق العمال وحتى
عن المعايير البيئيه وعن استعداد قطر
ثقافيه وفكريا استضافات البطوله القطريون
رد باتمان كافه الاستعدادات لاستضافه
الفرق الرياضيه والمشجعين من كافه انحاء
العالم وباصلاحات تشريعيه سباقه في
المنطقه فهل تلعب هذه الاطراف التي وصفها
وزير الخارجيه القطري بالقله في الوقت بدل
الضائع في قصتنا ما وراء الهجمه على
استضافه قطر للمونديال نرصد انطلاقه
الحملات على قطر من الصحافه البريطانيه
حيث نشرت مقالات وقصص اخباريه يغلب عليها
التحريض ضد قطر غير ان المحرك عنوانه
المصالح الماليه والتوجهات اليمنيه
المعاديه للمسلمين فريقنا تعقب اثر رائحه
النفط التي تفوق من حملات الزاني ماركت
قطر والزواديتها في ملف حقوق الانسان كما
رصدنا الموقف في فرنسا حيث قررت بلديات
اتباعها سياسه الشاشات السوداء كما سمتها
بينما مؤسساتها شريكه في مشارعها عديده
هنا في قطر تستكمل بقيه القصه مع السيد
ناصر الخاطر الرئيس التنفيذي لبطوله كاس
العالم 2022 نساله عن كيفيه تعامل اداره
البطوله مع هذه الهجمه ورؤيته لاسبابها
وعن مدى تاثيرها في استعدادات اللحظه
الاخيره وبيلا انطلاق البطوله لكن لنشاهد
القصه ومن بعدها نبدا الحوار
قطر
[موسيقى]
توت بنتي 2 فيفا فولكاب اي اس كاكا
من ديسمبر 2010 وقبل ان يفضل حضور لم ترك
للبعض دعوات فيفا للتطور نحو بلدان جديده
عندما خلص التصويت لمنح قطر حق استضافت
كاس العالم 2022 فبريطانيا التي سحبت
ترشيحها لتنظيم نهائيات 2002 بهدف كسب ملف
تنظيم نهائيات 2018
وكانت قطر العنوان الرئيسي لهذه الحملات
[موسيقى]
فيفا
اساس من الصحه
[موسيقى]
ريزن
اولها وضعوا قطر كدوله صغيره بالنسبه لحجم
الدوله فهذا موقف لا معنى
الدوله ليكون مناسبا ان يقام فيها مثل هذه
الفعاليات
من الدول الكبيره
في اوروبا
كان 66% منها سلبيا و29
[موسيقى]
الصحيفه المحسوبه على الشعبويه البريطانيه
اليمنيه كانت 80 بالمئه من تغطيتها
لاستضافه قطر لكاس العالم سلبيا الصحيفه
ومؤسسات اعلاميه كبرى اخرى من بينها شركه
تعود ملكيتها الى رجل المال روبرتوك
اعترضت الشركه على قرار الفيفا بعقد كاس
العالم في الشتاء لما سيكلفها من خسائر
هائله حيث تمتلك المجموعات حقوق بث
بمليرات دولارات لمواسم رياضيه تعقد عاده
في الجاردينيا
[تصفيق]
الاسباب الرئيسيه للاعتراض ان اقتصاديه او
سياسيه
قطر فيجب ان تؤجل من الصيف الى الشتاء ما
اثر على عوائد عدد كبير من الشركات ومحطات
التلفزه الغربيه وبرزت كذلك مساله قناه بي
ان سبورت المملوكه لقطر والتي استحوذت
مسبقا على حقوق بث الفعاليات في عدد كبير
من الدول الاسيويه وبلدان الشرق الاوسط
ايان المساله في جزء منها كانت متعلقه
بالعوائد وثاره اشاعات وتسريبات حول تقديم
ارضا بمايين الدولارات
من قطر الى مكان اخر
[موسيقى]
العالم 2022 على 43%
محاوله ربطها بما وصفته بالاسلام المتطرف
الصحيفه المحسوبه على يمين الوسط المحافظ
كانت من اوائل الصحف التي رسخت ربط
الاسلامي بمفاهيم التطرف منذ التسعينيه
وقد دراسه بعنوان دور الصحفي البريطانيه
في تشكيل المواقف المعاديه للاسلام
والمسلمين
الذي يمارس تاثيرا كبيرا على طريقه اداره
الامور السياسيه
ويجب ان تضم المنظمات والبطولات الرياضيه
الكبرى
العالم الذي لا يحق له استضافته هذه
البطوله
الحملات التشهير بملف قطر في الصحف
البريطانيه بلغت ذروتها في محطتين الاولى
الحشد الاعلامي لسحب ملف المونديال من قطر
بدعوه فساد الفيفا عام 2011 و 2014 وانتهت
باعلان لجهه الملف القطري عقبه نشر نتائج
تحقيقات اجرتها لجنه الاخلاق بالفيفا
استمرت لعامين
ثقافه كره القدم لكن هذا ينطبق على
الولايات المتحده عندما نظمت كاس العالم
عام 94 وكذلك اليابان في 2002
طارت في حاله جنوب افريقيا المرحله
الثانيه عام 2021 تمثلت بنشر صحيفه
الجاردن لما اعتبرته كشفا عن عدد وفيات
العاملين في انشاء قطر
منذ البديل بانشاء البنيه التحتيه لكاس
العالم
وعندما تحدثنا معه منظمه العمل الدوليه
ومنظمين كاس العالم وجدنا الارقام اقل
بكثير وعلى مدار 10 سنوات فسيكون هناك عدد
من الوفيات واذا نظرنا في اسبابي هذه
الوفيات نعم كانت هناك وفيات في مواقع
الانشاءات وخلال العمل لكن ايضا كانت هناك
وفيات جراح حوادث الطرق حسنا في المملكه
المتحده لدينا حوادث الطرق ولا ناتي ونقول
انا قوانين العمل خاطئه اذا كانت لدينا
اسئله مهمه لم نتلقى اجابات واضحه عليها
حول كيف تم الوصول الى هذه الاوراق
لكم لكم
تنظيم كاس العالم في روسيا حينها لم تكن
روسيا قد غزت اوكرانيا ولكنها كانت قد ضمت
شبه جزيره القرم وكانت حقوق الانسان قد
انتهكت في روسيا في ذلك الوقت ظهرت
انتقادات لكن لم اكن مخطئه لم يكن هناك
حديث عن المقاطعه
قطر تتعرض لهجمه هي الاشراس اعلاميه
بالمقارنه مع دول الكبرى لاسيل الصين
وروسيا وفقا لدراسه اعدتها هيئه مراقبه
اخلاق ولوائح الفيفا وعلى الرغم من
الاصلاحات النوعيه التي اجرتها قطر وكان
على راسها اصلاحات نظام الكفاله ورفع الحد
الادنى للاجور وحمايتها ومنح العمال
المهاجرين حق تقديم ممثلين عنهم كسابقه هي
الاولى من نوعها في الخليج الا ان تغطيه
هذه الاصلاحات في الاعلام الغربي جاءت
متواضعه
سامسونج
الاخبار سيئه مفضله على الاخبار الجيده
وقد لمسنا هذا في تقرير منظمه العفو
الدوليه الذي نشر مؤخرا فقد خلص التقرير
الى ان تغييرات كبيره اجريت واعترف بها
لكن الاعلام فضل التركيز على الجوانب
السلبيه المتمثله بالتقصير في تطبيق هذه
التغييرات وهذا ينطبق بلا شك على معظم
التقارير الغربيه
[موسيقى]
بما في ذلك عاملات المنازل وهو الاول في
العالم من هذا الجانب لديهم قوانين خاصه
بالاجهاد بسبب الحراره
في اختيار مكان السكن لم يعد هناك وضعوني
يكون فيه العامل مملوكا لفردا اخر وبينما
لا يزال معظم العمال يعيشون في مساكن فقد
تم تطويرها ويتم اعاده بنائها بشكل تدريجي
ولم تعد المساكن ذات الحاله السيئه قيد
الاستخدام
[موسيقى]
الشيء الذي اثار اعجابي هو وضعه حد ادنى
للاجور وضمن مستوى المعقول من وجهه نظري
حيث يتضمن الاجر اقامه وواجبات مجانيه
وعند مقارنه ذلك بالمملكه المتحده وجدت ان
متوسطه اجر العامل يبلغ بعد الضرائب الفن
الى الفا ومئه باوند
الادنى للاجور هنا وبعد ان يدفع العامل
اجره المسكن والطعام الى ذلك والتي تبلغ
حوالي 800 باوند لا يتبقى له سواه حواليه
200 باوند وعند احتساب القدر المكافئ
للعمال في قطر نجد ان القيمتين متساويتان
تقريبا
[موسيقى]
لقد قارن بين اعداد العاملين في مواقع كاس
العالم وبين العاملين في مواقع الانشاءات
الاسلاميه والتجاريه في المملكه المتحده
وقد وجدنا ارقاما متماثله من الحوادث
الاقامه وشروط الرعايه الصحيه وما اثار
اعجابي فعلا هو الرعايه الصحيه المقدمه
للعاملين والتي يمكن مقارنتها بما تتلقاه
في المملكه المتحده
[موسيقى]
كنافه
فهنا في فرنسا المتاثره داخل اليمن
كاس العالم اخذت هذه الاصوات تعلو اكثر
فاكثر والسياسه في فرنسا تتخذوا منحا
متطرفاوبيا في فرنسا مرتفع مع ذلك شخصيا
ارى ان الدعوات في فرنسا لمقاطعه كاس
العالم تاتي في الغالب من اشخاص لا يهتمون
كثيرا او لا يهتمون بكره القدم ومع ذلك
يبدو انه كره القدم غالبا ليسوا في وارد
دعوات المقاطعها
فيسبوك
بطريقه مختلفه بدلا من الاحتجاج قبيل
البطوله لكننا نرى نوعا من سلوك القطيع
هنا هل بعد يحتاجون واخرون يدفعونهم
كالقطعان هناك من يحتاجون بنيه حسنه لكن
اخرين لهم مارب اخرى
على الصعيد الرسمي ساهمت شركات الفرنسيه
كبرى في تنفيذ رؤيه قطر الوطني 2030 من
حيث البنيه التحتيه والاقامه الرياضيه
ووفق الخارجيه الفرنسيه فالمنشات الفرنسيه
الراسخه في قطر وعلى وجه الخصوص في
التحضير لبطوله كاس العالم 2022
رقصات الموت
المقاطعه اولئك الذين لا يحبون ان يرى
بلدا مسلما ينظم بطوله كاس العالم
على تنظيم المونديال
[موسيقى]
منذ اختيار قطر لتنظيم كاس العالم لكنها
حين ذات كانت متعلقه
لكن دون اي دليل ملموس
علينا ان نستثمر كاس العالم
مواقف بعض الدول الاوروبيه المنوئه
للاستضافه العربيه منذ اعلانها لم تكن سرا
لكن مواقف بعينها انقلبت في نقطه تحول
فعلى هذه الرقعه الخضراء في اسباير
الاكاديميه الرياضيه القطريه وقبل سته
اعوام تحديدا في مارس 2016 قدم الامير
فريدريك اندريك وليعهد الدنمارك وعقيلته
الاميره ماري الدعم الكامل لقطر في
مشروعيه الرياضي بصحبه وفد رفيع المستوى
من مسؤولين الدنماركين وطرح نجم كره القدم
الدنماركي اي بيسان
كره القدم في نشر الوعي بثقافه الطاقه
النظيفه
في هذه الصوره التي استوقفت زار الامير
فريدريك ووفده شركه مارسكويك كبرى الشركات
الدنماركيه والتي عملت على تشغيل اكبر حقل
النفطيا في قطر منذ العام
1992 بموجب اتفاقيه اعلنت قطر عدم تجديدها
في النصف الثاني من عام 2016 معتبر ضربه
قاسمه للشركه التي تساهم باربعه عشر
بالمئه في الناتج الاجمالي المحلي
عرضتها لبيع اصولها شركه نفطي
بطوله كاس العالم في قطر
انت
اجاباتهم لا نستطيع الاجابه عن هذا السؤال
كلا لن نقاطع ولكن يجب ان نوجه الانتقادات
اي انها اجابات في معظمها متردده فلا احد
يريد ان يقاطع فعلا
شركه الملابس الرياضيه الدنماركيه عام
الانترنت والاتحاد الدنماركي لكره القدم
راس حربه في حملات لم تجد غضاضه في اعتماد
شركه هامل في 93% من انتاجها على عماله في
دول تم الابلاغ فيها عن مخاوف بشان حقوق
الانسان وقوانين العمل ومنها دول تمارس
العمل القسريه على الاقل لديها للعمل في
شركات البسه الكبرى ووفقا لتقليل رويترز
مواجهه تصميم الشركه الرفض من جهات رات
فيه حيله تسويقيه لزياده مبيعتها كون
الفريق الدنماركي هو الوحيد الذي تعاقد مع
عمل كمصنع للاطقم الخاصه بهم لكاس العالم
2022 في حين حصلت شركات الالبسه الرياضيه
الاخرى على عقود مع فرق عده
عارفين
ان تتدخل الشركات في مساله حقوق الانسان
بحقوق الانسان
ومحاولته ايجاد فرق على الصعيد السياسي
وما مد ارتباطه بالمال وبرغبتك في بيع
منتجاتك
جدا
في المملكه المتحده والتي كانت تهدف الى
تخفي ديون العالم الثالث
بيضاء وتبين انها مصنوعه في الصين وجزء
منها ربما من خلال عماله مضطهده لذا انهم
نجد هنا ازدواجا في المعايير
[موسيقى]
اما الاتحاد الدنماركي لكره القدم ستلاحقه
اتهامات بالعنصريه ليس بدا بانتقاص حقوق
المنتخب الدنماركي لكره القدم للسيدات
برفض الاتحاد مساواه اجورهن المتدنيه
باجور اللاعبين الذكور علاوه على المعامله
سيئه لهن والاستعداد الرديء لبطولات
السيدات والانتهاء بالشعارات العنصريه
التي ترفع في مدرجات الملاعب الدنماركيه
حتى تجاه الاوروبي غير الدنماركي
[تصفيق]
افكار
جديده
الانسان
يريدون مناقشه موضوع قطر الوطني
[موسيقى]
في ايسلندا قابلنا ادم
المفوضيه الاوروبيه
على تتبع ممارسات العنصريه في الدنمارك
ليصدر تقرير المفوضيه في يونيو 2022 من 44
صفحه
[موسيقى]
الكلمات المستخدمه في القانون الدنماركي
وفي الحديث السياسي في الدوله
[موسيقى]
ناس غير غربي
الحاره الجزء السادس
الكثير من الناس من انحاء العالم كافه
اشتروا بطاقات المباريات بسرعه مثل كعك
العيد
اتساءل ما اذا كانت ما تزال هناك بطاقات
ام انها بيعه جميعها
سوف اشاهد كاس العالم كاس العالم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جدا بتلك الملاعب فهم بناها وهؤلاء العمال
المغتربون هم الذين ساعدوا في بناء اقتصاد
قطر وشيد البنيه التحتيه التي هي اساس
الاقتصاد ويستحقون الاحترام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نرحب بكم مجددا المشاهدين الكرام وبضيفي
الكريم السيد ناصر الخاطر الرئيس التنفيذي
لبطوله كاس العالم لكره القدم في قطر لعام
2022 الاستاذ ناصر اهلا وسهلا فيك شكرا
لقبول الدعوه نعرف ان جزاكم مزدحم كثيرا
لكن هناك بعض النقاط التي تبقى تنتظر
توضيح للجمهور العربي الذي ينتظر بفارغ
الصبر هذه البطوله التي يعتبرها ايضا
سبقوا ان صرحت وقلت ان هذا اليوم فعليا هو
اليوم الحقيقي لانطلاق البطوله وانه سيكون
شعور مميز بالنسبه اليك شخصيه يشعرك
ايه صراحه يعني الناس كلها تنتظر 20
نوفمبر ليبيد بطوله كاس العالم لكن احنا
فعليا بالنسبه لنا وفرق العمل بدل عمل
بشكل جاد اا قبل فتره واحنا فعلا حسينا ان
احنا دخلنا اجواء البطوله
ودخلنا في عمليات البطوله بشكل كبير
من يلعب في الوقت بدل الضائع قطر مستعد
واعلن ذلك يقولون بانكم على اتم الاستعداد
لكن هل العالم مستعد ان يستضيف بلد عربي
مسلم هذه البطوله بهذا الحجم في منطقتنا
العربيه
بشكل كبير
الصحف
المحطات الاعلاميه وسائل الاعلاميه اللي
هي كانت ضد قطر من اليوم الاول قطر تعرضت
لحمله شرسه من اول ما فازت بيترشح او
باستضافه كاس العالم
طبعا بدل الموضوع بحجم قطر
الامور تغيرت مع الوقت واحنا رجعنا الحين
شفنا انا نفس الامور اللي هم كانوا
يتكلمون عنها في الاول اللي هو المناخ
قلنا عدم ارس كروي في كره القدم مثل باقي
الدول ال ال الدول الاوروبيه تحس ان هذا
انه بطوله كاس العالم هي حكر لدول اوروبا
احتضنت 11 بطوله من اصل 22 بطوله طبعا ما
ترضى ان دوله مثل قطر او دوله عربيه مسلمه
تستضيف بطوله مثل كاس العالم
على سؤالك في كان تقريبا 40 مليون طلب على
تذاكر كاس العالم تنبيع ثلاثه مليون منها
اللي هي ثلاثه مليون اجمالي عدد التذاكر
المنتخب كلها
عدد الجمهور اللي راح يجي قطر احنا كنا
نقول دائما بين المليون ومليون و200 واحنا
الحين على الوتر الي قاعدين نمشي فيها على
حجوزات الطيران وحجوزات الفنادق ان شاء
الله راح نوصل لهذا الرقم فكل المؤشرات
اللي يشوفها بالارقام عارف ان شاء الله
راح تكون استضافه ناجحه لكاس العالم
الموضوع لان ايضا الهجمه صارت مكثفه
وتعالت الحده مؤخرا قال بان النفاق عدم
موضوعيه ازدواجيه المعايير هي السبب وراء
ذلك تبعنا في فيلم الليله رصد لمواقف بعض
الدول نتحدث عن جهاد ايضا اما في في
بريطانيا كانت جهات اعلاميه وراء الموضوع
الثاني مارك اتحاد كره القدم همم يعني عده
جهات كانت وراء هذه همم الانتقادات
وراينا ايضا في المقابل بانها ليست ايديها
ليست بريئه تماما يعني هناك ازدواجيه
حقيقيه في المعايير انتم كيف تعاملتم مع
هذه الانتقادات منذ البدايه
موضوع الانتقادات في انتقادات لازم يتمرد
عليها ان كان رد اعلامي ان كان رد قانوني
همم طبعا ليس كل شيء يكون على على المراه
الجميع في بعض الانتقادات
يعني
الانتقادات على المراه الجميع يعني وسائل
الاعلام العالميه لم تدخر جهدا في ذلك
وكانت حملها شرسه وهناك من فقد تسمح لي في
ذلك انه لم يكن مستوى رد الفعل من قبل قطر
على مستوى الهجمه التي حدثت
الاولويه هي نجاح هذه البطوله والتركيز
على تنظيم هذه البطوله باكمله الوجه همم
في بعض الانتقادات اللي صارت طبعا احنا
على 12 سنه انتقادات تعودنا عليها في
انتقادتها كثير ردي لنا عليها بشكل صريح
على في الوسائل الاعلاميه وفي بعض عضلات
تستحق الرد عليها جرائد صفراء يعني يمكن
نقدر نقول كل الجرائد اللي احنا كنا همم
نتوقع منها المصداقيه ونتوقع منها
الشفافيه
المسؤوليه المهنيه في في في المجال ااا
صارت كلها جرائد صفراء للاسف
فمات يعني ان احنا نرد عليها كلها لكن
اللي تستحق قررت كنا نرد عليها ان كانت
بطرق فعاليه
قصته في الفيلم سته الاف 1500 من العمال
الذين توفوا جراء هذا في الانشاءات تم
تكذيبه صحيح همم في قطر وحتى من منظمه
العمل زمان
تحدثت بان هذا الرقم خطا وحتى يعني يعني
بعض الوسائل الاعلام اعتذرت عن ذلك لكن لم
نسمع رقما من عندكم ما هو الرقم الحقيقي
يعني لم يكن هناك رد رسمي يوضح الاموره
يضعوها في اطارها الصحيح
الفيلم اللي تم عرضها اشكركم عليه اولا
لان لخص كل الانتقادات اللي ضغطت لها قطر
من فوسه استضافه كاس العالم الى اليوم
وفتندتهم وايضا اشرحها كثير من ال- من ال-
من الامور اللي كانت همم يمكن مش معروفه
للناس يعني رقم 6500 اذكرها منظمات ان هذا
رقم خاطئ انه هم المنظمات او وجهات
الاعلاميه اللي روجت لها هذا الرقم وهي
الجارديان والجارديان يتاسفت ان هي عرضت
هذا الرقم بشكل خاطئ هم هم يعني خذوا
اجمالي ارقام الوفيات على مدى سنتين او
ثلاث سنين وضربوها بعشر سنين
6,500 ماتوا في بناء استعدادات كاس العالم
الوفيات للاسف طبعا اللي صارت في انشاءات
كاس العالم ثلاثه
معقول لمده 12 سنه منذ ان اعلم ثلاث وفيات
نعم طبعا احنا عندنا معايير الصحه
والسلامه في السادات على اعلى المستويات
همم طبعا همم في نقطه مهمه قالت ان بعض
الامور الاعلام يحب يذكر الامور السيئه
والسلبيه احنا ذكرنا هذا الرقم اكثر من
مره لكن الجهات الاعلاميه لا تحب ان تذكر
الارقام هذه
فعلا
هو لا يهتم بالامور الجميله والطقس
الجميله يعني نحن للاسف نركض وراء الاخبار
السيئه وهي التي تتصدر لعناوين من هنا
اعود للسؤال مره اخرى كيف بنيتهم
استراتيجيتكم لاعلاميه في الرد على كل هذه
الافتراءات والادعاعات الادعاءات من وجهه
نظركم
بشكل كبير وبس لما ذكرت ان احنا بعض
الردود كان لازم نرد بعض الافتراءات
والاتهامات كان كنا لازم نرد عليها ان
كانت بطريقه اعلاميه او ان كانت بطرق
قانونيه في بعضها يعني انا اهتمام وشفنا
مع الوقت هذه الاتهامات ومن من الجهات
والانتقادات من الجهات همم يعني لها اهداف
اهداف سياسيه اهداف نقدر نقول ان فيها
عنصريه بشكل كبير ان الدوله مثل قطر دوله
عربيه اسلاميه دوله صغيره قدرت ان هي
تقارع وتنافس دول كبيره يشوفون انهم احق
باستضافه هذه البطوله يعني ان قلنا خلص
استراتيجتنا نركز على عملنا نركز على ان
تكون نسخه كاس العالم في الوطن العربي
الاولى تكون من انجح كاس العالم
هذه نقطه مهمه يعني
مونديال العرب منذ اليوم الاول مسؤولون في
قطر اكدوا على ذلك 450 مليون عربي هم
سعداء جدا دافعوا بشراسه حتى على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لما تعرضت وتتعرضت قطر
لهذه الحمله هاشتاجات يعني
اكيد من الدول العربيه انا عربي ادعم قطر
هناك وعي في العالم العربي بهذا الموضوع
حتى على المستوى الرسمي كما ذكرنا هناك
على الا ظاهرا دعم لملف قطر وهمم وقفه ضد
هذه الحمله الشرسه هل تدركون حجم
المسؤوليه التي تقع على عتيقكم فعلا ما
الذي يمثل هو اول لكم ان يكون هذا
المونديال فعلا الممثله تكون قطر سفيره
العرب همم وتقديم صوره ربما جديده للعالم
طبعا احنا من البدايه همم هذه البطوله
تمثل كل العرب وهذه البطوله لكل العرب همم
زيدنا حماس تزيدنا بالحساس بالمسؤوليه
طبعا
وتزيدنا همم
رغبه في نجاح هذه البطوله بالنيابه عن كل
العرب
المنطقه في غير يعني العناوين التي تتصدر
عاده للاسف في النزوح والتشرد والقتل
والحروب والماسي سار العالم فعلا همم
المنطقه العربيه بمنظور جديد كيف
استعددتهم لذلك هي استعداداتهم
الرسمي او الخطاب الاعلامي من الغرب دائما
كان انه
يصور المنطقه ان هي منطقه حروب ومنطقه
نزاعات طبعا بالنسبه لهم هذه البطوله اكبر
بطوله رياضيه في العالم انذار 3.2 مليار
نسمه راح تترجع الى قطر خلال بطوله كاس
العالم هذه راح تنسى طبعا ال ال الصوره
اللي كانت ترسم عن هذه المنطقه همم ان شاء
الله مليون نسمه راح يكون موجود في خطر
خلال بطوله كاس العالم هذا راح يكون سفير
للمنطقه سفير لقطر عندما يرجع ويقول اللي
شافه في قطر همم
من معالم من تعرفها على الناس من المنطقه
اللي راح يكونوا متواجدين اثناء كاس
العالم فطبعا هذا مثل ما قلنا يعني الشعب
العربي واعي شعب العربي يمر بهذه اللي
احنا قاعدين نمر فيه دائما همم العنصريه
همم طبعا الصوره النبطيه اللي يحولون
يرسمونها عن المنطقه وان شاء الله ان شاء
الله يعني بطوله كاس العالم راح يتغير من
هذه الصوره
في الانتقادات الاخرى همم هناك مناطق اخرى
من العالم 11 مره البطوله اقيمت في اوروبا
فقط همم يعني هذا يدل على الكثير هناك من
لا يتحمل ربما ان يعني المنطقه غير اوروبا
وغير هذه الدول الغربيه المتقدمه الكبير
انت تستضيف هذه البطوله اود ان اقف معك
همم قليلا مع منطقه من العالم في الواقع
لها في كره القدم استضافت كاس العالم ولم
تسلم هي ايضا من الانتقادات البرازيل لا
يعرف البرازيل حتى ان كنت لست من متخصصين
في الفوتبول لكن نعلم بان الفريق
البرازيلي له باع في هذه المسابقه
البرازيل التي خصنا في الواقع وزير
الرياضه السابق فيها خلال فتره قبول ملف
البرازيلي لاستضافه كاس العالم وهو نائب
حالي في البرلمان البرازيلي سيد اورلاندو
سيلفا خصنا بمقابله ولديه وجهه نظر ايضا
حول نظره الغرب لاستضافه الدول تحت خط
الاستواء لهذه المناسبات الرياضيه الكبرى
معنا نتابع استاذ النصر
او لا
تتعرض لظلم ونظره استوائيه غير عادله
وتعاني من من يتعمدون تجاهلها كثيرون لا
يعرفون هذا البلد جيدا ولم يتعرفوا على
تاريخه وثقافته ولكن لديه نظره عرقيه الله
وهي اوضح نموذج لهذه الصوره التي يريدون
تقديمها عن اختلاف الثقافات يريدون ان
يظهروا ان نتقافه الاوروبيه والغربيه
وكل ما ليس وفقه مع غيره يتم التعامل معه
في التعامل مع القضيه هذا المنطق ظهر
عندما استضافت البرازيل كاس العالم وعندما
استضافت جنوب افريقيا كاس العالم الدولي
طبعا كانت هذه وجهه نظر الوزير الاسبق
البرازيلي وهي وجهه نظرت وشاطر وهو العديد
من الدول
التي ربما لم تحظى بهذا الشر تحتقدون بان
استضافه قطر ستفتح همم مجال لدول اخرى
مثلما تقول في استكشاف ارادم جديده
كثافه السكر في العالم هو عند الخط
الاستوائي طبعا كانهم دائما يتكلمون عن
الجو الجو في الخط الاستوائي في الصيف
الجو حار فطبعا ال- ال- الكون قطر استضافه
البطوله في فصل الشتاء فتحت افاق الناس
قالوا انه مستحيل انك تستضيف بطوله في في
فصل الشتاء نحن البطوله في فصل الشتاء بعض
الدوريات راح تتاخر شويه او همم يعني شل
تاثير الكبير اللي راح يكون عليها اتوقع
انه راح نشوف دول اصغر من الدول اللي اللي
عادت تستضيف البطولات راحت تستضيف راح
نشوف ايضا ممكن بطولات تقام في الشتاء
اللي عادته
يعني
قلت لاننا همم
المسابقه في الشتاء حتى هذه النقطه التي
انتقادات كبيره ويكون الموضوع البيئه
هذه الملاعب المفتوحه على العالم سواق لها
الغرب على انها كارثه بيئيه همم يعني بما
تردون على هذا الموضوع ما الذي قدمتموه في
موضوع البيئه التي هو موضوع مهم جدا
بالنسبه للغرب والمواطن الغربي
في كثير من السادات وكل المنشات الرياضيه
يتم تدفئتها في فصل في فصل الشتاء وطبعا
نحن نعرف ان التدفئه هي تستهلك طاقه اكثر
من التبريد هذه اول نقطه الثانيه ان احنا
كنا دائما نتكلم على ارث اللي راح تتركب
بطوله كاس العالم ومن اهم ال- ال- هنسميها
المكونات هذا الارث هو الارث البيئي احنا
احنا
التشييد وبنائر السادات همم تم على همم
اسس صديقه للبيئه ايضا نحن وعدنا ان هذه
البطوله راح تترك همم ايضا من ناحيه بطوله
خاليه من الكربون او صديقه للبيئه
انبعاث الكربون بانكم يعني وعدتم لكنكم لم
تفو بشكل كامل في هذا الموضوع
همم دشرت اول
او 700 بلانت اليوم
اللي هو الطاقه الشمسيه توليد الكهرباء
بالطاقه الشمسيه
هذا مع الاثنين اللي راح تيجي راح تكون
بالفائده على هذه البطوله لانها راح تكون
همم قطر راح تستخدم الطاقه الشمسيه ليه
استفاء همم طلب الطاقه وايضا تعاهدت قطر
انه في خلال الخمس سنين اللي جاي او ل30
راح تكون 20% من حاجز قطر للطاقه من
الطاقه الشمسيه في هذا الطبعه كلها يعود
على كاس العالم
همم
الانتقادات صحيح ان قطر سباقه في المنطقه
في ما يخص نظام العمل الكفاله لعلكم باقي
الدول في المنطقه بهذه الخطوات الكبيره في
هذا الموضوع حقوق العمال لحد الادنى
للاجور والكثير الانسان انشاء صندوق
لتعويضات ايضا الكثير من التفاصيل الا ان
الغرب حتى في هذه النقطه دي انتقادات وهي
انتقادات وجهها يعني يتم التشكيك في انك
تقوم بهذه الاصلاحات حتى تمشوا حالكم يعني
وبعد كاس العالم ستعودون عن الاصلاحات
وتتراجعون عنها بما همم يعني تردون على
هذه اتهامات
يعني ما راح تنتهي الانتقادات واتوقع ان
ايضا في وقت البطوله راح يحاولون ان
يدورون شيء على اساس انه تاخذون قطر
بسببه الضغط على قطر من خلال كاس العالم
احنا بدنا نرجع نشوف رؤيه خطر 2030 اللي
تم اصدارها في 2008 تكلمت على حقوق العمال
او وراء فهيتهم واحنا دائما قلنا ان هذه
البطوله اي واحد ممكن يستضيف بطوله كرويه
او رياضيه وتكون هي بطوله عابره وتنتهي
احنا قلنا لازم نوظف هذه البطوله ونستخدم
هذه البطوله للتقدم همم
من اهم المكونات اللي احنا شوفناها في
رايت 2030 ان كيف احنا نتقدم في ملف
العمال والعماله في قطر طبعا هل ننكر ان
كاس العالم سرعت في وتيره هذه الاصلاحات
والتقدم لا بالعكس كاس العالم كم من اهم
الاسباب اللي صار في تغيير الجذري في
العشر سنين اللي فاتت وانا تحدي اي دوله
ان كانت اوروبيه او في امريكا الشماليه او
امريكا الجنوبيه قدرت تقوم باصلاحات في
فتره قصيره مثل ما قطر تشريعات تغيرات
بناء مساكن للعمال بمستوى رفيع جدا كلها
كانت يعني تفضل الرؤيا رؤيه 2030
وطبعا كنا عارفين انه في كاس العالم هذه
لازم الامور نحطها يعني خمسه منها على
الفاستراك على وتر سريعه
جدا لكن وسائل الاعلام مره اخرى الغربيه
منذ يومين او ثلاثه ايام فقط كنا نتابعه
على وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه تم التسلل الى
مساكن عمان وهم يعيشون في ظروف صعبه
وقاسيه نتساء هل لديكم فراق تفتيش هل
تذهبون
لمعاينه الواقع غير الذي تقول التقارير
ربما التي تصيبكم وتكون مغلوطه
ومن 2016 لليوم قاموا بتغريبا فوق العشر
الاف حمله تفتيش على مساركن العمال
يعني هذه مرحله وهذه راح تاخذ وقت في
تشريعات في مثل ما قلنا المسار كان يتم
بناءها في معايير جديده وضعناها لكن هذه
تاخذ وقت لانه يكون في تطبيق لها ايضا نحن
ما نقدر نتوقع عنك كل شيء يتغير في يوم
وليله عشر سنين مش فتره كبيره لتغيير نظام
بشكل كبير لكن مع الوقت احنا نقدر نقول
انه في المنطقه العربيه احنا قطر رائده في
هذا المجال لكن طبعا على اساس انه يكون في
تطبيق على ارض الواقع بشكل كامل راح يكون
في وقت طبعا انا صحفي اقدر اطلع الخطا
واقدر اطلع الصح ما شفنا الصحفيين جاوب
راح يشوفونا التغيير
لا لا هذا الكلام غير صحيح بالعكس هذا
الكلام اللي يقول ان فيه ناس طردوا لتوفير
مساكن للمشجعين هذا الكلام غير صحيح في
بعض الحالات همم حصلت كون بعض ملاك
العقارات استغلوا انتهاء عقود
لايجاد فرصه بالنسبه لهم انه ممكن يستفيد
من كاس العالم بيرفع الايجارات لكن ان ان
بشكل
هذا الكلام هذا
ضروري التركيز اللاعبين والفرق على اللاعب
وليس مدونه لماذا ما التخوف ما الذي
تتوقعونه ما الذي تقوله لوائح الفيفا ان
حدثت اي امور قد لا ترغبون فيها على
الملاعب او حتى تصريحيه همم
شعارات سياسيه شعارات همم ليس لها علاقه
بكاره القدم ممنوعه طبعا يكون في رقابه
شديده على هذا على هذا الموضوع
بطوله كاس العالم هي بطوله كرويه تحدث كل
اربع سنين نعم هي بطوله توحد الشعوب دائما
على كره القدم خاصه في البلد المضيف في
البطوله هذه طبعا دائما يحاولون يستخدمون
الجهات اللي عندها او المؤسسات اللي عندها
اجنده معيها يستخدمون بطوله مثل هذه لكن
شفنا ان بطولات قطر صراحه استغلوها الناس
بشكل كبير لاجلدات معينه ان كانت اجنده
اجندات اللي هي حقوق المثليين والى اخره
هذه بطوله رياضيه هذه بطوله كره القدم
الجمهور اللي جايه حابب يحضر مباراه كره
القدم مش جاي يشوف همم منصه بنتكلم على
الامور السياسيه لان الناس يشوفونها في
بيوتهم على الاخبار الناس يبغون ينسون لذا
تكلموا وقال رئيس الفيفا خلونا نركز على
كره القدم هذا البطوله لكره القدم
الاستمتاع للجماهير تستمتع في هذه البطوله
ايضا احترام همم القوانين البلد ثقافه
البلد هناك من استغلها بشكل سلبي في تخويف
الجماهير القادم ما الذي تق تقصدون ما
الذي تنتظرون من مشجعين
2010 الى 2018 شفت ان اغلب الجمهور يحترم
البلد اللي هو فيه يحترم القوانين وما
نشوف مشاكل بشكل كبير
فاحنا متوقعين ان ال الجمهور راح يجي هنا
طبعا في تعدد ثقافات وفي تعدد طرق
الاحتفال للجمهور واحنا ايضا لازم نكون
نظيفين ونحترم ايضا تقاليد ولكن المهم
انهم يحترمون القوانين وانا ما يكونوا
يعني انما ما يهددون امن وسلامه الاخرين
وانفسهم اكيد
الوجع الراس والصداع
قطر يعني
المتابعين وصفوا ذلك يعني احنا استطلعنا
حولنا استطلاع الاراء غلبيتهم جاءت جمله
تتكرر كثيرا حسنا من عندي انفسهم يعني
جلبت فقط ال- ال- الانتقادات اللي بنظره
الان الى الوراء هل كان الموضوع يستحق
عنها ما الذي ستجنيه قطر الذي همم يعني
تتوقع ان يتركه همم هذا المونديال المنطقه
ايضا
يعني بالنسبه لنا كنا عارفين انا راح يكون
في انتقادات كبير على دوله عربيه دوله
صغيره مسلمه تستضيف هذه البطوله شفنا
شراسه الحمله استمرت مدار على على طوال
الفتره طبعا ممكن تتخذ ان احنا اخذنا
المركز الثاني واحنا قرانا الولايات
المتحده لكن هم فاز ولكن احنا يعني
منافساتنا يعني وصلتني للمركز الثاني وكان
ممكن نقول انه هذا بحدات انجاز اخر قطر
تحب التحدي وتحدث من قبل
وقطر استغلت هذه البطوله مش لنجاح بطوله
وبس استغلت هذه البطوله العمل الجاد
استغلت هذا البطوله في البلد همم اللي
يشوف قطر قبل 10 سنين ما راح يعرف كيف كيف
اصبحت بالعكس وظفنا هذه البطوله من صالح
المواطن والمقيم على على قطر وايضا بتكون
بطوله استثنائيه وتكون بطوله ايضا تشارك
في العرب
في عجاله وفي جمله اخيره لان وقت المخرج
بان الوقت انتهى ما الذي تقولونه للمشجعين
القادمين الى قطر في كلمه اخيرا
نقدم لكم بطوله مذهله وبطوله استثنائيه
وان شاء الله راح تكون بطوله انتم
تستمتعون فيها وترجعون بذكريات ايجابيه
وترجعون ذكريات
تخليكم ترجعون على قطر
شكرا
المدير التنفيذي الرئيس التنفيذيه كاس
العالم 2002 2020 على قبولك الدعوه نتمنى
لكم التوفيق شكرا شكرا شكرا
كده مو حلقتنا دمتم في رعايه الله والسلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]